Obama's re-election is great for moms
right aren't we just a bunch of mindless
free spenders still in love with
humanity we want to support every cause
and child as though they were each our
own hi hales know from jobs to health
care to education let's face it ladies
we're screwed and not in the much needed
50 shades of grey way this election all
boiled down to choice because now ours
are sadly limited to make a simplistic
sexist argument how would you like it if
you waltzed into the shoe department at
Nordstrom or Bloomingdale's and instead
of ankle booties and wedges you found
one or two styles of sensible
comfortable clogs to borrow a term from
Joe Biden malarkey with the employer
mandate small businesses are now
compelled by law to provide health care
for their full-time employees what will
this do will it bolster families and
working moms by offering free medical
care to those in need hardly many small
business owners desperate to stay afloat
will abandon full-time employees for
their lesser trained part-time brethren
to stave off government insurance
mandates better to have three part-time
knuckle-draggers than to well-qualified
full-timers and that means fewer hours
and smaller paychecks for working
families who would have otherwise had
greater health care choices and would
have been able to attain private health
care on a full-time salary more families
will be pushed to qualify for Medicaid
but according to the washington times
sixty percent of physicians to take it
or not accepting new patients and once
you're in that system your choices are
greatly diminished you don't get any
choices the other maternal fleecing
comes from education well sure race to
the top the president's tiny pilot
program implemented in 11 states says it
has choices but it's really a drop in
the bucket as far as real reform the
administration is pushing national
standards which will lead to an even
more centralized education system now
that is a tepid and impractical response
to anyone who has more than one kid we
all know even if they come from the same
womb their needs are vastly different
and why should we assume if they come
from the same school district or state
their differences needs would be any
less stark choice is not a four-letter
word and it's not just about abortion
choice is at the heart of an election
whose fallout promises to limit mobility
and the most important and hard-fought
areas for reason TV
I'm Kennedy